ein schwarzes loch im zentrum unserer
milchstraße um welches ein stern rus und
zwar mit sagenhaften 25 millionen
kilometern pro stunde
ein forschungsteam hat sich dieses
spektakel jetzt mal genauer angesehen
dabei ist es den wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftlern tatsächlich
gelungen das erste mal überhaupt die
sogenannte gravitations rotverschiebung
an einem schwarzen loch nachzuweisen
eine weitere bestätigung also für die
allgemeine relativitätstheorie von
albert einstein wie so oft alle
wichtigen infos zu dieser entdeckung und
noch zwei weitere phänomene die
einsteins theorie bestätigen bekommt er
jetzt bei pixum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierende songs
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
vergleichs ein stein bestätigt durch
gravitations rotverschiebung vielleicht
kennt ihr ja das gerüchten nach dem nur
etwa drei leute auf der erde
albert einsteins allgemeine
relativitätstheorie verstehen können wie
haben sie erklärt das video ist verlinkt
in der video beschreibung viel zu
komplex scheint sie denn diese theorie
25 jahren unserer zeit vorstellung
nämlich dass zeit immer gleich schnell
vergeht nach einstein wird die raumzeit
durch materie verformt je dichter und
schwerer die masse ist desto mehr wird
die raumzeit gekrümmt hier auf der erde
ganz schwach dadurch werden wir hier auf
der erde gehalten im extremfall sucht
hast das alles in diese delle in der
raumzeit fliegt und gefangen ist und
nichts mehr aus ihr heraus gelangt nicht
einmal licht dieses objekt kann die
gigantischen massen von einigen bis zu
millionen sternen verschlingen und hat
eine unvorstellbare anziehungskraft auf
alles es sind schwarze löcher die sich
durch ihre wirkung auf die umgebung
verraten eines davon existiert auch im
zentrum unserer milchstraße und zwar 26
tausend lichtjahre von der erde entfernt
alle 15 jahre wird es von dem stern s2
umrundet dieser nähert sich dem
schwarzen noch bis auf 14 milliarden
kilometer
diesen abstand den kann man sich
vorstellen wie den dreifachen abstand
zum neptun also von der sonne ton also
dem äußersten planeten unseres
sonnensystems das forschungsteam vom
max-planck-institut bei münchen hatte
diesen stern mit dem very large
telescope der europäischen südsternwarte
eso beobachtet sie stellten fest dass er
dabei eine unheimliche geschwindigkeit
erreicht nämlich knapp drei prozent der
lichtgeschwindigkeit also mehr als 25
millionen
zudem machten die wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen eine beobachtung
die einsteins theorie mal wieder
bestätigt und zwar wird das licht des
sterns röther und zwar durch die starke
gravitationskraft des schwarzen lochs
einstein hatte vor 100 jahren in seiner
theorie festgehalten dass solche eine
gravitationskraft die lichtwellenlänge
wachsen lassen müsste das licht des
sterns vertreter dazu stefan gillessen
einer der beteiligten forscher
das ist das zweite mal dass wir den
nahen vorbeiflug von es 200 schwarzen
noch in unserem galaktischen zentrum
beobachtet haben aber diesmal konnten
wir den stern aufgrund des deutlich
verbesserten instrumente mit bisher
unerreichter detailauflösung verfolgen
und schließlich die gravitative
rotverschiebung im spektrum vernetzt
zwei nachweisen
insgesamt 26 jahre hatte das
forschungsteam darauf hingearbeitet
solch eine gravitations rotverschiebung
zu entdecken
herzlichen glückwunsch zu diesem erfolg
fall zwei entdeckungen der
gravitationswellen bestätigt ein stein
aber nicht nur in diesem zusammenhang
gelang des forschungsteams einsteins
theorie in der praxis zu belegen und das
jahrzehnte nach der entstehung seiner
relativitätstheorie nach der aufstellung
der relativitätstheorie auch bei den
gravitationswellen war es ähnlich wir
hatten dazu berichtet als der nobelpreis
für physik im jahr 2017 auf einstand
spuren wandelte konkret waren des rainer
weiss gibt von und barry bersch die
tatsächlich einsteins formeln berg
bestätigen konnten ja die messung von
gravitationswellen ist nicht nur für die
physik welt eine sensation auf diesen
moment hatten weitaus mehr als 1000
forscherinnen und forscher hin
gearbeitet und am 14 september 2015 551
amerikanischer ortszeit lag rainer weiß
einer der beteiligten forscher
erstens noch im bett und zwar zweitens
im urlaub und weit weg von seinen beiden
kilometer langen d lektoren die
plötzlich erzitterten erst dachte er nur
das ist ein fehlalarm war ein pseudo
signal von seinem forschungsteam um zu
testen ob die datenauswertung auch
sauber arbeitet doch dann war klar dass
das system nach einem update für solch
einen fehler noch gar nicht bereit war
und das war der große moment der von
jetzt auf gleich alles veränderte nach
jahrzehnte langer suche hat der mann
gravitationswellen gemessen ausgelöst
durch den zusammenstoß von zwei
schwarzen löchern und wie immer in der
wissenschaft die solch eine entdeckung
noch deutlich mehr wert wenn sie
wiederholt werden kann und tatsächlich
auch folgende messungen bestätigten den
nachhall solcher kollisionen bei dass
dafür den nobelpreis fällig war reine
formsache
fall 3 gravitation beschleunigt alles
gleich schnell einstein hatte wieder
recht nach einsteins allgemeiner
relativitätstheorie beschleunigt die
schwerkraft alle objekte gleich schnell
eine feder beispielsweise genauso
schnell wie einen sehr schweren stern
zumindest in einem äußeren
gravitationsfeld das kann man auch als
die allgemeingültigkeit des freien falls
bezeichnen oder als äquivalenzprinzip
egal wie die masse oder zusammensetzung
eines objektes ist eine bleikugel würde
genauso schnell zu boden fallen wie eine
feder wenn ja wenn es den luftwiderstand
nicht gäbe das konnten forschungsteam
schon vor längerer zeit im labor
überprüfen beispielsweise mit einer
eisenkugel und einer feder im vakuum
doch ob diese theorie auch für objekte
mit einer sehr starken eigen gravitation
gilt das blieb lange zeit offen doch im
vergangenen jahr konnte ein
internationales forschungsteam eine
antwort auf diese frage finden zeigen
sterne beispielsweise abweichungen von
den vorhersagen der relativitätstheorie
die antwort lautet ganz klar nein
einsteins theorie beschreibt auch die
umlaufbahn von himmelskörpern mit
starker schwerkraft richtig dazu
untersuchten die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler ein system aus zwei
weißen zwergsternen und einem
neutronenstern dabei gelang es ihnen das
4 1200 lichtjahre entfernte stern system
auf wenige hundert meter zu vermessen
so konnten sie genau verfolgen ob der
äußere weiße zwerg aufgrund seiner
schwerkraft das enge paar des
neutronensterns und des weißen zwergs
beeinflusst ihre sehr genaue messung
konnte jedoch keinerlei abweichung im
verhalten der massen zeigen heißt also
ein stein behält recht mal wieder es ist
wirklich absolut irre wie exakt einstein
alles vorher gesagt hat und das nur
durch nachdenken
immer wieder gibt es dazu verrückte neue
forschungsergebnisse und wenn er keins
davon verpassen wollt dann abonniert am
besten auch den englischen kanal vom
krieg zum denn da gibt es auch
faszinierende videopremieren dafür
einfach hier klicken
darunter geht es weiter mit what do
aliens look like ich freue mich auf euch
auf dem englischen kanal zu tun
stay tuned